[Music]
nathan is with us in gainesville florida
hi nathan welcome to the ramsay show
hey thank you all for having me on sure
what's up
my question today is i have i'm closing
on a house august 5th um
and i currently have a car i owe 8 800
on i could resell it for 15.
um
but i've had kind of a hard time finding
anything that's even slightly reliable
around that six to seven thousand mark
so i'm wondering if i should just
punch out
paying it off or
search for something that will
you know work for around that price
i would continue to do the research and
and get a 7 000 car
before you get into this house
what's your other plan if you don't do
that
if you
my other plan is that to keep the car
pay it off and i have quite a bit of
repairs i need to be doing on the house
i'm currently living
rent free with my grandpa so i don't
have to worry about
payments until i get the house which um
is
you know next month
um
but i've budgeted all that out i've used
every dollar and
uh i think i'll be i'll be fine with the
the payments but what do you make a year
um around 40. no whining sell your car
and find a 6 000 car
and don't tell me there's no such thing
as a 6 000 car that's reliable that's
absolute bs
yeah
okay dude you're about to get yourself
in a pinch rationalizing your butt off
here
okay yeah yeah you're trying to do 17
things at once you know what you're
supposed to do you just wanted one of us
to tell you what kind of car is this
that you have
um it's a passat volkswagen
get it board you need to sell that
anyway just get a honda or toyota
and you'll be fine yeah yeah just get
you an old honda you might have a toyota
mileage they'll go 300 000 miles easily
that gum honda accords man they really
never just die they never really die
they just kind of exploit them if you
wanted to just go forever
yeah you got to just do some shopping
around and and here's the thing you just
don't want to sell the car
you just don't want to make the move you
don't want to downgrading car you
shouldn't have boxed yourself in if you
want to keep this car but now you got
this house that needs all these repairs
you make 40 grand a year you're living
with your grandpa do you do these
repairs you got this house payment
coming on on a house that still needs
repairs and now you're talking about
keeping a car payment no
i feel stressed just hearing all that
made me stressed
yeah i want to get into this house and
have it be a blessing and not a curse
and that means no debt no payments other
than we're focusing on this house we
tell folks all the time nathan you
included don't buy a home while you have
debt
what
yeah really because murphy will move in
your spare bedroom sally may will move
in the other bedroom heat and arrow go
out the first week you move in the roof
will leak the third week you move in
you're asking for trouble when you move
into a house with a bunch of debt
and people rationalize it all the time
and they keep getting more and more debt
more and more debt more and more debt
and then they get stressed out and then
they get the they get the crap knocked
out of them by life then and so but i i
do the same thing i i try to figure out
a way to get to do all the stuff i want
to do at the same time we're none of us
like saying no even to ourselves
but
i guess it's kind of one of our
spiritual gifts here at the show we're
supposed to be here just to tell you
what you already knew
uh no you don't need to keep this car
uh if you were going to keep this car
you shouldn't have bought this house and
too late you've already bought this
house so yeah you need something's got
to go and if you can get out from under
this car and make profit i'm doing that
oh definitely